the Taliban have ordered an immediate
and indefinite ban on University
education for women thousands of Afghan
girls sat University entrance exams just
three months ago the ban is the latest
of many restrictions on women's rights
most girls are already barred from
secondary school education
and journalist Ali latifi joins me now
from Kabul Ali are you surprised at all
by this move
um you know there's been talk about
something like this happening for weeks
months and it's one of those things
you don't want it to be true and so even
when the the interesting thing about it
is that the news really broke later in
the evening around 8 8 30 in the evening
so it seemed very odd for people that
you know such an edict was coming out
essentially in the middle of the night
um not early in the morning not even in
the afternoon so that initially created
a lot of Suspicion but you know within
minutes it became very evident that no
this was legitimately what people have
been fearing for the last you know year
and a half uh since the Islamic Emirates
since the Taliban returned to power so
it's one of those things it's not
surprising unfortunately given their
track record but maybe in the way it
happened and just you know
obviously when it happens it will be a
surprise to people no matter when or how
it occurs yeah
yeah why are we seeing this now
there was discussion
fears of course ever since the child
of power
this is exactly this is the question
right uh that as you all said earlier
you know thousands of girls sat for the
University entrance exam I interviewed
them you know they had sat for it in
several different provinces uh education
officials bragged you know it's all
about education officials brag that so
many uh young women were sitting for
University uh entrance exams and really
the the timing why it's happening how
it's happening there's still no clear
answer there's just a lot of guesses and
conjecture but really amongst the people
it's anger it's it's upset because their
whole thing has always been you know if
you claim to be an Islamic Emirate why
are why are you not following the rules
and teachings of Islam because there's
nothing in you know Islamic teachings
that would forbid anyone male or female
from being educated or you know for
going to work or you know going to
because they're not allowed workplaces
for going to parks and her moms which
have been recently banned to girls and
women
and so the question keeps coming back to
people is if you claim to be an Islamic
Emirate why are you doing the most
unislamic things yeah the Taliban
promised to allow girls to go back to
school now they are banned from schools
and universities is the Taliban
leadership possibly divided over the
treatment of women
it's very clear that they're divided
because if you look at it you know you
have high ranking officials who have
said things like we need to restart the
the you know the secondary school for
girls in 32 provinces out of the 34
where it's not allowed at the moment
um you know saying that women aren't are
an important part of society and you
know you know they have
economic fares and and business fares of
you know female entrepreneurs but how
are you going to continue to have these
if you are not allowing women to be
educated who will be a female
entrepreneur you know two three five
years down the line if you cannot have a
university education you know
um or even really a high school
education so it there's this really
weird back and forth among the Taliban
where on the one hand you have people
who say things like oh we're not keeping
women from doing certain things or we're
not as strict as we used to be or you
know our edicts are being misunderstood
or we want to create more of a role for
women but nothing they've done has
actually shown that is there any hope
for improvement in the future
only hope is if the Taliban realizes
that as the people say that everything
that they're doing is on Islamic and if
they realize that you know they are
failing in the same way that the former
Islamic Republic failed which is by not
understanding the Avalon people at all
and by assuming that what they Envision
as a way of life for the Avalon people
is what the people want which is the
exact same thing that led to the
downfall of Former Republic and led to
so much distrust among the former
Republican unfortunately it seems as if
the taliban's Islamic Emirate is
treading the same path
Ali latifi and Kabul mini thanks for
your time